foreign
[Music]
wherever you are tuning in thank you for
joining us for the next phase of Axiom
Spaces ax2 Mission on this early morning
the ax2 mission is the second all
private crew to the International Space
Station dedicated to expanding access to
low earth orbit for all you're watching
the live approach and docking coverage
of the ax2 mission as NASA SpaceX and
Axiom space began close proximity
operations with the International Space
Station hello I am Duke Brady a
multimedia specialist with Axiom space
and with me is Kate Tice quality systems
engineering manager here at SpaceX our
four-person Axiom crew will experience
10 days on orbit eight days on board the
ISS this webcast is a joint broadcast
between NASA SpaceX and Axiom space as
we will walk you through the events of
dragon approaching and docking with the
ISS and carry our coverage through to
the welcome ceremony that awaits the
crew once they are on board the
International Space Station
the ax2 mission officially started
yesterday Sunday May 21st when the Axiom
crew lifted off from historic pad 39a at
2 37 PM Pacific 5 37 p.m Eastern the
crew inside Dragon spacecraft is now in
position to begin approaching the
International Space Station now let's
check in with the teams at Johnson Space
Center who are actively monitoring
Dragon Freedom's progress
good morning Kate and Duke and welcome
to the International Space Station
flight control room I'm NASA's Leah
Cheshire and dragon has been chasing
down the International Space Station for
almost 14 hours now since that launch
yesterday and we are just seconds away
from the approach initiation burn
now the approach initiation burn is
going to bring Dragon up about 400
meters below the International Space
Station so about a quarter of a mile and
it's also and we just heard the call
that the AI burn has begun we're
probably going to hear some chatter
between the crew and the ground here
throughout the morning
the teams here in Mission Control
Houston are being led by flight director
Marcos Flores
of these systems aboard the
International Space Station
okay we'll move into this round three
then
and to the right of Marcos Flores is our
Capcom Justin cartilage he is working
with the teams aboard the International
Space Station speaking with the
astronauts there
again the AI burn is underway this is a
firing of the Draco thrusters on Dragon
it's about a 90 second burn
and it's going to bring us up now
completely until we're about 400 meters
copy that four decimal zero one zero
complete
that call from Commander Peggy Whitson
aboard dragon that they are now in their
suits and I have good calm checks
and we have confirmation of a good AI or
approach initiation burn
we had nominal AI maneuver completion
reminder of c2v2 link is lost for 10
minutes without ground Action Dragon
will perform a breakout timers are
available in your event details
and Dragons
and Dragon SpaceX on the big Loof let's
try this again 144k bi-directional link
is established change your PTT
destination to ISS and then initiate
contract with SpaceX Houston and station
Dragon copies on the big loop so drag
into SpaceX how do you read
and dragon I believe you still have
ground set elected to your PTT
And1 completion ground
very very uh dragon how do you read it
on the Big Moose
and Dragon SpaceX on dragon ground um
[Music]
[Applause]
and I have you five by five on the big
loop
right and station dragon on the big boot
how do you
think Dragon station has you land clear
looking forward to seeing you guys
likewise
and Houston Station on the big league
Houston reach you five by five how many
we have you love and clear as well
and SpaceX dragons dragging the ground
how do you read
and John I have you five by five help me
sounds good thanks
as you can hear we are up and running
this morning you heard a lot of calm
checks when we were discussing the big
loop this is a loop created so that the
space station dragon and the teams on
the ground in Hawthorne and here in
Mission Control Houston can all
communicate on the same loop our Cronus
flight controller set that up this
morning and dragons on Dragon the ground
for suit leak checks
uh dragon Go
hey John you have a go to perform for
decimal zero one one to start your suit
leak checks
okay sounds good we'll go through simply
checks dragon
the ax2
crew members are already in their suits
this morning
and we did at the start of today's
broadcast just have completion of the
approach initiation burn dragon is now
about 400 meters below the International
Space Station
it has also passed into the approach
ellipsoid we call that the AE that's an
imaginary shape measuring a four
kilometer by two by two kilometer
essentially a large three-dimensional
oval
this means dragons on a 24-hour station
low priority
uh dragon ready
hey John I was just wondering did that
Echo resolve itself
yes sir you're crystal clear now thank
you very much
that's good to hear thanks
the crew reported hearing an echo just
moments ago before we joined the
broadcast today when they had multiple
Loops set up for communication but now
everyone is established and speaking on
the big loop meaning all teams involved
can hear the communication
we are tracking docking to the node 2
Zenith or the space-facing port this
morning at the International Space
Station at about 8 10 a.m Central Time 9
10 eastern time so moving right on time
now 14 hours and two minutes since
launch yesterday afternoon
and Dragons Basics you are go to
initiate suit leak checks
which one
again we are here in Mission Control
Houston this morning monitoring dragons
docking to the International Space
Station scheduled for 8 10 a.m central
time but we have teams in Mission
Control Hawthorne monitoring dragon's
flight since launch yesterday as well so
I'm going to send it back to Kate and
Duke
awesome thanks so much Leah we did hear
the call out that they got the crew got
the okay to begin the suit leak check
um as Leah mentioned before they donned
their suits a little bit ago and that
leak check is basically just inflating
the suits a little bit and monitoring
the pressure for a couple of minutes
just to make sure that
um once now that their suits are back on
all those zippers are in the right place
and the visor is latched and locked and
ready to approach it's great it's great
to hear all those healthy calm checks as
well
as the dragon begins its approach to the
space station let's learn a little bit
more about the ax2 crew
the ax2 mission is commanded by retired
NASA astronaut Peggy Whitson born and
raised in Beaconsfield Iowa she was
inspired along with the world when she
watched the Apollo 11 crew walk on the
moon she has since become the most
experienced American astronaut and one
of the most decorated Woodson flew three
long duration missions to the ISS and
has more cumulative time and space 665
days than any U.S astronaut and more
than any woman in the world she has
conducted 10 spacewalks with over 60
hours out in the vacuum of space and has
performed hundreds of research
experiments on board the ISS not only is
she the commander for this Mission but
Peggy also serves as the Director of
human space flight for Axiom space
the pilot for ax2 is private Astronaut
John schoffner born in Alaska and raised
in Kentucky schofner is a steam
education Advocate business Pioneer and
lifelong space Enthusiast a pilot since
the age of 17 John has over 8 500 flight
hours holding commercial instrument
single engine and multi-engine ratings
in land and sea aircraft as well as
helicopter he also holds ratings in
former military jets and high
performance
we show four Goods leak checks here
and ground concurs
all right good news there just letting
us know that all the suit leak checks
checked out
as an athlete John has years of
competitive experience in water skiing
cycling White Water kayaking hang
gliding skydiving and base jumping John
trained as the ax2 excuse me ax1 backup
pilot and during this Mission plans to
invest a lot of his time in Steam
education activities aimed at empowering
Educators and inspiring teachers
and representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as a mission
specialist Ali al-karni was born in
March 1992 and sobbed alalea Saudi
Arabia Ali is fluent in English as well
as his native Arabic and as an Air Force
Captain Ali has 12 years of experience
flying on multiple aircraft primarily on
the f-15sa in service to the Royal Saudi
Air Force Ali graduated with a bachelor
of Aerospace science degree in 2013 from
King Faisal Air Academy in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia
also representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as a mission
specialist Rihanna barnawi was born in
September 1988 and Jeddah Saudi Arabia
Brianna has a master's degree in
biomedical Sciences from alphaisal
University in Riyadh Saudi Arabia and a
bachelor's degree in biomedical Sciences
from otago University and Dunedin New
Zealand she is fluent in English and
Turkish as well as native Arabic she has
been a research lab technician since
2013 in the stem cell and tissue
re-engineering program at King Faisal
Specialist Hospital and research center
located in Riyadh Saudi Arabia
and there you have it the ax2 crew this
is a fantastic wonderful group of people
who have spent months and thousands of
hours preparing for this moment we are
so proud of them and it's so awesome to
finally see them in space yeah we had an
opportunity to actually hear from the
crew just I was like about three hours
after uh they made it to excuse me uh
yeah after they got into space
um that uh in orbit on-orbit media event
was awesome we got to see and hear from
Peggy John Ali and Rihanna and it was
just so cool to see them floating around
and spinning their water bottles and
playing with the um the zero g indicator
and yeah it was just a lot of fun to see
them play it really was great now
today's crew as we said Peggy Whitson
John troughner Alia Carney and Rihanna
barnawi have gone through extensive
training around the globe to be ready
for their 10 days in space each crew
member has between 700 and 1 000 logged
hours of time since mid-2021 dedicated
to learning these SpaceX protocols ISS
systems and to prepare for the science
and Outreach activities that they'll be
conducting while in space
private Astronaut training is rigorous
to prepare the ax2 crew for their
mission our teams here at SpaceX have
spent the last several months teaching
the crew about orbital mechanics how to
live in microgravity and running
simulations full of missions from inside
our dragon training capsules
the training program includes nearly 100
different lessons covering all all
aspects of the flight
and the list of training goes on there's
a lot more that they did and we'll try
to recap some of it the ax2 Chris spent
time in simulators to orient their
bodies to the conditions that may be
experienced during the course of the
mission including into a centrifuge
right here simulating higher g-forces
alternatively the crew also participated
in a zero g Parabola flight that
simulated the lack of g-forces to
experience weightlessness seems awesome
but aside from the scene aside from the
simulating gravitational forces they
will experience over the course of their
Journey they also underwent altitude
training and a hyperbaric chamber this
training simulates high altitudes where
oxygen levels are low and the crew uses
this to identify how their bodies
respond to hypoxic situations as well as
recognizing those effects in their
crewmates
to be ready to spend eight days on board
and working on the International Space
Station they've spent time learning from
Mission controllers experts in safety
and emergency ISS procedures as well as
the essentials to living on board the
orbiting laboratory things like how to
heat up your food where to find all the
equipment you need Etc the goal is to be
able to competently confidently complete
every task on their timeline but to also
be contributing members of the space
station as a whole as other astronauts
carry out their duties
and to that end this crew will be
working in areas on the ISS that are
owned and operated by other countries so
the crew traveled to Germany and Japan
to be qualified on those systems the
European space agency's Columbus module
was in Cologne Germany where they
trained on systems and operations for
daily tasks as well as responding to
contingencies separately to qualify for
the Japanese exploration module or gem
the crew traveled to scuba Japan to
learn from the instructors
from the Japan from the Japan Aerospace
Exploration Agency as you can imagine
International collaboration is a
constant throughout this Mission so it's
one thing to learn the systems of ISS
but it's just as important to understand
how to live and work as a team in a
shared space and so the team spent five
days training in the human exploration
research analog or Hera at the Johnson
Space Center this is a confined
experience that just is designed to
isolate the crew to build cohesiveness
and teamwork this experience included a
chance to simulate work and research
procedures rehearse rehearse Outreach
efforts and even respond to mock
emergencies all while living in close
quarters unable to leave
team also spent time at the launch pad
in the pseudoproom and working through
emergency procedures that might be
necessary in the unlikely event of a pad
abort scenario so it's pretty cool to
see absolutely and you know all of this
training culminated in a final patch
hanging ceremony at Johnson Space Center
to Mark the end of this Cruise training
this is a tradition of NASA's that dates
back to the beginning of the ISS 20 plus
years ago all that is to say this team
is ready to go and the last few months
have all led to the Here and Now what
they accomplish on station is going to
help write the guidebook for our next
missions and how we coordinate efforts
on our future Axiom station
needless to say this is also an
important moment for those training
Crews as really they become a family and
feel so connected after all that time
together now on your screen we have our
first view of dragon this view comes to
us from the International Space Station
we can see the lights blinking uh
indicating its location and this is the
furthest away it will be on camera so it
is approaching the International Space
Station for those of you that have just
recently joined us we had confirmation
that the crew completed their suit leak
checks and those leak checks looked good
so they are in their seats they're
strapped in and they are monitoring the
progress of their approach to the
International Space Station
this is what traffic looks like at the
ISS
[Laughter]
UE very true
there's no doubt that the incredible
efforts of thousands of folks across
NASA over the last two decades have set
the stage for what is possible in low
earth orbit
the X2 mission is a critical step toward
opening those possibilities to a host of
new participants governments diverse
researchers manufacturers and more
here on Earth we're already seeing
benefits from research currently
conducted on the ISS from water and air
purification systems to testing medical
devices and Therapeutics
pretty amazing stuff
in addition to Tech demos and medical
research access to low earth orbit
allows for a connection to the Arts and
other Outreach opportunities
ax2 is the first of several proposed
missions in advance of Axiom station the
world's first commercial space station a
sustainable commercial low earth orbit
economy means expanded access to work in
space
it also frees up NASA and its Partners
to put their budget towards other
exploration programs while granting
space agencies around the world more
opportunities through commercial efforts
and over its lifetime the ISS has
accomplished an unprecedented feat
continuously sustained operations on and
off the Earth for more than 22 years
this is not only a true Testament to the
technology required to physically
achieve that but also to the
collaborative and Cooperative efforts of
thousands of people across the world to
ensure that multiple Nations agencies
and entities both public and private
work together to push Humanity forward
and as we move forward private
Industries need to learn need time to
learn how to re-establish to establish
and maintain these relationships
effectively so by flying private
astronaut missions like ax2 to the ISS
Axiom is taking essential steps to get
that on-the-job training as we work
towards building the words world's first
commercial space station
Axiom station is an opportunity to
continue the story of the ISS science
and research through cooperation and
collaboration for the benefit of all ax2
is this next chapter
so once again we are observing Dragon
Freedom as it approaches the
International Space Station the crew has
their suits on they're in their seats
and they are inside those blinking
lights that's so amazing to think about
and we will see those blinking lights
get closer and closer over the next
couple of hours everything uh when you
are approaching or departing the
International Space Station is highly
choreographed and
um it's it's really slow and that's for
safety purposes
um it's the the safer way and the best
way to do it so we will see Dragon get
closer and closer I you know even those
two lights that we see the red one and
the green one
um they represent the port and starboard
side and I never remember what color
goes to what uh but I can tell you that
we will start to see those get closer as
we have been even over the last few
minutes
you might be seeing some stars on your
screen but most of those dots are dead
pixels in that camera sensor and that's
that happens because of that high
radiation in space
now dragon is capable of carrying up to
seven passengers to and from Earth orbit
and Beyond it is the only spacecraft
currently flying that is capable of
returning significant amounts of cargo
to Earth and is the first private
spacecraft to take humans to the space
station dragon is fully autonomous which
means that it flies itself but it also
features full manual override
capabilities in case of emergency
standing at almost 27 feet tall from
bottom of the trunk to the top of the
nose cone crew dragon is composed of two
main elements the capsule which is
designed to hold crew and pressurized
cargo as well as an unpressurized
section which is known as the trunk
the nose cone at the top of the capsule
protects the docking system and also the
guidance navigation control system which
is the system that's being primarily
utilized right now as dragon is
approaching the International Space
Station
that nose cone opens for docking and
remains attached to the space stage it
gives me attached to the crew Dragon
spacecraft unlike previous versions of
dragon and that helps toward our efforts
toward reusability now opposite of the
nose cone is the trunk it provides
attachment points for Falcon 9 the
Dragon capsule and cargo one half of the
trunk is covered in solar panels that's
the black side of the trunk on the
exterior and those provide Power to
Dragon during flight and while on
station the other half contains a
radiator and it rejects heat from the
active thermal control system to space
using spacex's new Pika tiling
technology
the trunk also now has a new aerodynamic
has new aerodynamic fins which provides
stability in the event of an emergency
abort now in the event of an emergency
abort crew dragon is outfitted with
eight super Draco thrusters as opposed
to the just the regular Draco thrusters
and those power uh the astronauts to
safety Dragon super Draco launch Escape
system is a key safety feature of crew
dragon and it gives the crew the ability
to quickly separate from Falcon 9 and
safely escape from the time of launch
all the way to orbit it's a feature that
no other spacecraft in history has
possessed so it's pretty awesome and
it's a great safety feature absolutely
thank you Kate we are actually going to
toss back now to Leah at Mission Control
at Johnson Space Center Leah
thank you both very much and yes tally
ho we have sites set on Dragon now as
you can see it is pretty dark outside
that's because the International Space
Station is in an orbital nighttime
it's currently flying over the South
Pacific Ocean about 261 miles above
Earth and of course dragon is now just
slightly below it
Waypoint zero brought Dragon about or uh
sorry the approach initiation burn
brought Dragon to Waypoint zero at 400
meters below the International Space
Station
the systems have checked out and it's
now moving up toward Waypoint one that
is when dragon is approximately 220
meters uh above the space station it'll
be on the docking axis meaning it's
directly directly in front of the
docking port
so the crew are headed to the Zenith
Port the space to facing Port of node 2.
and the other Dragon that's currently on
board which brought the crew 6 crew
earlier this year that is docked to the
forward Port of the harmony module
as you can see we go in and out of
receiving feeds from the International
Space Station that happens when we go
through satellite Handover periods the
International Space Station is orbiting
Earth and seeing a sunrise in the sunset
every 45 minutes so we constantly hand
over to different satellites that
receive the feeds from the station and
send it back to us on the ground so
you'll see that a little bit this
morning
after we Reach Waypoint one we will
pause until Dragon Gets the go to move
into Waypoint two that's when they're
only 20 meters away from the
International Space Station and the
spacecraft is focused on aligning its
docking system with the international
docking adapter
slow and steady wins the race at this
point in the mission right now we're
moving at less than five miles per hour
and as we move in from Waypoint two
we'll be moving even slower we may hear
the call out chop at a little less than
30 seconds before docking that's the
crew hands-off point when any aborts
need to be done automatically by dragon
and of course we are tracking docking to
come in at about 8 10 a.m central time
this morning the crew are in their suits
they have completed good suit leak
checks everything continuing to move
along
very smoothly today
a look back at some of what was
completed last night shortly after
launch less than an hour after liftoff
at about 5 23 PM Central Time Dragon
executed the phase burn that was the
first of the five major Burns required
to raise dragon's orbit and position it
for approach to the space station
about seven hours later we had the Boost
burn that puts the crew in an orbit
where dragons apogee or the highest
point is about 10 kilometers lower than
the station after that we executed the
close co-eleptic burn at 12 51 a.m
Central Time
the close burn puts dragon on an orbit
roughly co-eleptic with the space
station that means it is roughly 10
kilometers lower than the station the
entire way around the earth instead of
just being 10 kilometers below the
station at apogee or its highest point
we also saw the transfer burn at about 2
47 a.m central time this morning that's
the fourth major maneuver where we raise
dragon's apogee again or the highest
point of its orbit to just 2.5
kilometers lower than the space station
we rounded everything out on the big
loop mid course burn complete and
nominal trajectory has converged on
Waypoint zero
thank you
and we just heard confirmation of a good
mid-course maneuver that's about halfway
through the Journey to Waypoint zero to
make sure dragon is positioned right
under the station again about 400 meters
below so confirmation that they did
indeed conduct a mid-course maneuver
this morning and everything continues to
look good for Dragon
we are in integrated operations this
happens when Dragon gets closer to the
space station specifically when they
enter the approach ellipsoid that four
by two by two kilometer invisible
boundary around the International Space
Station this helps us govern all
arriving and departing visiting Vehicles
whether they carry cargo or crew
we're also hearing good words about
teams being go to move inside the keep
out sphere that's another checkpoint
that consists of an imaginary sphere
around the station with a radius of 200
meters
they keep out sphere carries a similar
requirement on the orbital trajectory
that if Dragon were to somehow lose
control of its thrusters the space
station would be safe for four orbits or
about six hours however everything
looking good on Dragon this morning
again we're in an orbital nighttime this
view coming from the International Space
Station as we are tracking dragon and
its approach to the orbiting Laboratory
once Dragon arrives at the space station
today they will be greeted by seven crew
members currently living on orbit that
includes NASA's Frank Rubio Steve Bowen
and Woody hoberg Sultan al-niadi of the
United Arab Emirates and was Cosmos
cosmonauts Sergey prokopia Dimitri
patelan and Andre fajayev
that'll bring our crew up to 11 for the
next several days we are looking at
about an eight day docked mission for
the ax2 crew about 10 days in orbit in
total
the crew on the International Space
Station will be monitoring arrival this
morning specifically Woody hoberg of
NASA and Sultana of the United Arab
Emirates will be in the station's cupola
using special software to track dragon's
approach and make sure it stays in the
expected zones once dragon is docked
hoberg will be our Prime to start those
hatch opening operations
he will start by opening the large hatch
on the Node 2 forward or node 2 Zenith
that is giving him access into the
pressurized mating adapter they'll then
pressurize the vestibule and that's the
small space between the hatches on the
dragon and space station of course the
vestibule is exposed to vacuum prior to
docking so it's on the big loop Dragon
range is
or in one decimal one zero two drag and
approach and Retreat monitoring ISS crew
is now primed for vehicle approach
monitoring
that call up to the International Space
Station just as we were explaining
they are primed to monitor the arrival
of the ax2 crew today
again we're heading toward Waypoint zero
that's the 400 meters below station Mark
we are now 950 meters from station
closing in at about 2.9 miles per hour
copies
so once we dock at approximately 8 10
a.m central time it takes about two
hours to pressurize the vestibule the
space between the hatches
fly controllers here in Houston will
Monitor and verify the pressure readings
to make sure that everything is really
free before we get ready for approach
setup
go ahead
of the big approached
ground has pulled go for approach zero
and will be enabling the maneuver
shortly expected maneuver start time is
per your four displays reminder that
Dragon will continue through Waypoint
one to Waypoint 2 without stopping at
Waypoint one
short leaves passing through zero to one
good me back
good news from the ground to the crew
that coming from the core the crew
operations responsible engineer in
Hawthorne California at SpaceX
headquarters
to Commander Peggy Whitson aboard dragon
the team will not have to pause at
Waypoint one sometimes there's a pause
Associated there so they can check out
all systems but things are looking good
this morning to continue through dragon
now 800 meters away from the space
station
the International Space Station crew
members have been preparing for arrival
of dragon by moving and setting up some
laptops as well as crew alternate sleep
accommodations again we will have 11
crew members feels like a full house
aboard the station once the ax2 crew
arrives today teams also will do things
like feather the solar arrays or
maneuver maneuver them so that they
avoid any plumes from Dragon once it
gets closer to the station
it's also been a busy time on the space
station with another variety of
activities including a port relocation
just a couple of weeks ago the crew 6
crew boarded their dragon spacecraft and
moved it from Zenith the space facing
port on node 2 to the forward-facing
port so that is where the ax2 crew will
dock today to that Zenith Port however
the maneuver was to prepare for the
arrival of crs-28 the 28th commercial
resupply Mission from SpaceX to the
International Space Station that will
bring with it some new Soul arrays those
are called International Space Station
roll out solar arrays and those are
stored in the trunk of dragon that
Zenith Port it makes it much easier for
the canadarm 2 to help retrieve those
irosis for eventual installation on some
space walks later this year
we've had a handful of spacewalks happen
over just the last few weeks at the
space station including three Rose
Cosmos spacewalks to move and connect
and deploy a radiator as well as one
massive spacewalk to
report we
have recently had a spacewalk to prepare
for those uh upcoming solar array
installations
and hearing confirmation from the crew
aboard the International Space Station
that they themselves also have their
sights set on the approaching dragon
ahead of arrival of the crew today the
space station crew were moving through
their morning including preparing the
node 2 area 4 docking and hatch opening
as well as getting the required exercise
for the day
and here we have a new view of dragon
approaching the space station from the
International Space Station itself
again we are looking at docking exactly
an hour from now at 8 10 a.m Central
Time
this view from the International Space
Station while dragon is still 630 meters
away
again this is an entirely autonomous
flight for Dragon the crew aboard has
been trained that they can take over if
needed however things continue to move
smoothly this morning
the crew off duty time ended at 5 30 a.m
Central Time the crew got suited up
shortly after and the big loop was
configured meaning that team members
here in hot or here in Houston can speak
with teams in Hawthorne as well as on
the space station and on Dragon on one
big communication Loop rather than on
various different loops
being that it is an autonomous flight uh
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg and Sultana
nayadi of the United Arab Emirates will
be in the cupola just to monitor the
arrival of dragon they can also send
commands to the capsule if needed but
that's not anticipated
hoberg will then be primed for assisting
in pressurization of the vestibule and
the hatch opening operations
after docking and the welcome ceremony
All crew members will then move into an
ISS safety briefing making sure that
they are briefed on everything they need
to know while living aboard the
International Space Station for safety
purposes of course they go through a lot
of that training here on the ground
but it's a great refresher once they
arrive on board in the microgravity
environment
you might have seen a little bit of uh
lighting change
we are now entering into an orbital
daytime again we see 16 sunrises and
sunsets a day aboard the International
Space Station moving at 17 500 miles per
hour giving us an even better view of
dragon as it gets closer now about 500
meters from the orbiting lab
the space station and dragon are now
flying about 270 statute miles
just west of Chile
again we're heading toward Waypoint zero
that'll be at 400 meters below the space
station we are now at 480 meters below
the space station
the crew will not stop at Waypoint zero
they will continue to move through
once they make their way to Waypoint one
there will be a continued go no go to
allow Dragon to begin its approach to
Waypoint two that's located inside the
keepout sphere about 20 meters away from
the space station we do not have to hold
at way point one all of the systems have
checked out and so we have that
opportunity to continue moving toward
Waypoint two however we do conduct a
hold at Waypoint two just to make sure
dragon is completely aligned with the
international docking adapter on the
Node 2 Zenith or space facing port
so at that 20 meter distance Dragon will
slow itself down even further bringing
its approach in
and eventually make initial soft contact
with the adapter soft capture ring
that'll retract and bring dragon in for
the hard capture sequence
now less than 450 meters away from the
International Space Station again we are
in integrated operations with teams here
in Mission Control Houston monitoring
dragon's approach to the International
Space Station along with teams in
Hawthorne California
the crew are in their suits they had
good suit leak checks earlier today they
also are seated
we have them get in their suits and
their seats during Dynamic phases of
flight even though it looks like crew
dragon is moving slowly we want to make
sure that they are in their suits as a
precautionary measure during the docking
process they had an opportunity to get
out of those suits have some free time
as Kate and Duke mentioned earlier they
were able to call down to the ground
last night and discuss what it was like
to be in microgravity
they also had a chance to get some rest
maybe eat some meals and then eventually
their crew rest time ended at 5 30 a.m
Central this morning
again you're watching live coverage of
the ax2 mission Axiom second private
astronaut mission to the International
Space Station these are not NASA
astronauts arriving aboard Dragon today
one of them however is a former NASA
astronaut Peggy Whitson
this is her third spacecraft to fly on
she joins a small Elite group of
astronauts who have flown on three
separate spacecraft she has flown on the
space shuttle on the Russ Cosmos soyuz
and now on Dragon
since NASA opened up the space station
for commercial activity in 2019 we've
continued to work with Private Industry
to prepare for the future of low earth
orbit and our long-term long-term goal
is to be not just the provider of a low
earth orbit destination but to be a
customer we want to be one of many
customers purchasing commercially owned
and operated services so we need to work
together today to ensure this path of
Tomorrow enabling these private
astronaut missions helps us to refine
and mature any of the processes we need
for that future so our NASA astronauts
are working side by side with private
and professionals approach zero has
started and trajectory has converged on
Waypoint one expected arrival at
Waypoint one is per year four displays
yeah I can copies
again we have reached Waypoint zero that
400 meters directly below the
International Space Station coming up we
are going to move from Waypoint zero to
Waypoint one pausing at that distance of
approximately 220 meters putting dragon
on the docking access axis meaning it's
directly in front of the docking port
as mentioned previously all of the
visiting spacecraft take the phased
approach to the International Space
Station they stop at predetermined gates
for the teams to run quick checks on the
vehicle performance before approaching
the orbiting lab
when it comes to bringing two spacecraft
together slow and steady wins the race
as docking operations require a great
deal of precision to make sure we're
keeping the spacecraft and the crew safe
so when we say slow and steady wins the
race we're now traveling at less than
half a mile per hour
again we are in integrated operations
during this time meaning teams from both
Hawthorne Hawthorne on the left of your
screen and Mission Control Houston on
the right are monitoring uh dragon and
the International Space Station
Additionally the Axiom Mission Control
here in Houston Texas as well is
continuing to monitor the flight they'll
remain on Console this week
on the big loop
all right prior range is 400 and stable
attitude as expected
Houston copies
the Axiom team will work with the ax2
crew aboard the space station this week
to ensure all of the payload operations
that they'll be conducting as well as
any of their downlinks with team members
on the ground as well as media and
potentially some stem Outlets will be
executed smoothly
again we are in a satellite Handover of
the tracking data and relay satellite
system these are tracked throughout
the flight we see this with the
International Space Station as well as
on Dragon multiple different customers
around the world use these satellite
systems
all seven crew members currently aboard
the International Space Station
currently moving about their day some of
them exercising some enjoying their
midday meal others are working on
various payloads and scientific research
aboard the International Space Station
there are some constraints as we move
into integrated operations specifically
during docking and once the spacecraft
is soft docked there will be an exercise
constraint
we don't want any additional loads
imparted on Dragon so any vibrations
that can be caused from using say the
treadmill or the stationary bicycle we
want to keep that from again imparting
those additional loads to ensure a safe
and smooth docking for Dragon so the
crew will be asked and are not timelined
to perform any workout activities during
that time
this view from the International Space
Station currently flying 266 statute
miles above the South Atlantic Ocean
dragon is about 400 meters away from the
space station again we reached Waypoint
zero and have the go to move to Waypoint
one which will put us 220 meters from
the space station above the docking ax
or on the docking axis above the node 2
Zenith port
after we Reach Waypoint one we'll move
into the keep out sphere that's the 200
meter uh sphere with a radius of 200
meters around the International Space
Station again this is an invisible
boundary but helps us monitor all
vehicles that arrive and depart the
orbiting Laboratory
for any Maneuvers at this point we are
seeing Dragon use its
service section Draco thrusters these
each provide 98 pounds of force there
are 12 of those dracos
those are only used in the vacuum of
space it's good for these attitude
control Maneuvers and those are grouped
into four clusters of three thrusters
each
onboard Dragon also has super dracos
these are only used for pad or Ascent
abort scenarios so these are currently
disabled they are disabled after the
ascent portion of the mission
there are also four forward bulkhead
Draco thrusters these are located
underneath the nose cone they're used
for larger burns like the G orbit burn
however we're not looking ahead at that
currently we expect that to come about
eight days from now we are planning for
this crew to spend eight days aboard the
International Space Station
also located underneath the nose cone is
the docking hatch this is the portion
that will dock to the International
Space Station and the hatch that crew
members will use to float in and out of
dragon
this is in contrast to the side hatch
that the crew used to board the
spacecraft yesterday that they will also
use to depart the spacecraft after
Splashdown and being pulled aboard the
SpaceX recovery ship
pretty quiet here in Mission Control
Houston as well as obviously aboard
Dragon any International Space Station
as this is a fully autonomous flight and
everything continues to go well for
Dragon and its arrival this morning
again dragon has reached Waypoint zero
and is making its way to 8.1 220 meters
above the International Space Station
and its intended destination this
morning which is the space facing hatch
on node two so with that I'm going to
send it back over to Hawthorne for a
status update Kate and Duke
thanks Leah
continuing to follow dragon's progress
as it gets closer and closer to the
International Space Station we're now
just .45 kilometers away from the ISS
and as Leah mentioned slow and steady
wins the race
now there are teams that supporting this
Mission from multiple locations this is
Johnson Space Center located in Houston
Texas this mission control room is
staffed 24 hours a day seven days a week
365 days a year team members are trained
in a variety of disciplines and monitor
all station systems in addition to this
control room we have the mission control
room here at SpaceX headquarters in
Hawthorne California that's the view
there on the left hand side of your
screen
that is where our teams are monitoring
dragon and checking in on all of its
systems and then of course the the Axiom
control room on the right hand side yeah
yeah right there for Axiom space our
team is there admission control in
Houston as well
uh it's pretty fantastic from this
secure facility we have live access to
all the voice video and data from the
ISS and can work alongside other NASA
counterparts to run on-orbit operations
and monitor every aspect of the mission
in real time
it's led by what we call our axle or our
Axiom operations lead and there are
various positions around the room for
research Communications medical
integration stowage timeline operations
Etc
it's pretty a significant step in our
journey as a company to expand access to
low earth orbit as it's the only only
the 12th Crown segment partner for the
ISS program so through this facility we
are enabling our customers in the global
Community a front row seat to the work
being done on station
so as you can see lots of people
supporting this Mission from all
different locations it really is a team
effort to execute these integrated
operations uh successfully and part of
the reason is as you can see it's not
just the four crew members that are
inside Dragon Freedom right now
approaching the space station it's the
whole integrated International Space
Station team as a whole once the ax2
crew arrives on station there will
actually be 11 crew members total and
it's going to be pretty exciting like
Leah said a full house and but the ax2
crew is going to be super busy they have
a lot of science and research planned
and they will also be contributing to
the station as well as the other
crewmates that are are up there with
them absolutely This Crew has a very
full schedule while on station and
actually a lot of that time will be
focused on some pretty fascinating
efforts for the sake of this
conversation that we'll have right now
the science set they're doing is
organized into a few categories like
life sciences physical sciences Tech
demonstrations
Etc
so with physical science this includes
some radiation protection research as
well as some storm related research
helping to create rain and cloud seeding
really fascinating stuff like that and
as well as enhance our understanding of
dangerous thunderstorms there's actually
a phenomenon called transient luminous
effects which are upper atmospheric
lightning or ionospheric lightning and
it's awesome that that that research
could potentially help operations at
Kennedy Space Center as we saw yesterday
there was an anvil cloud rolling in and
um you know it's really interesting how
this research that the ax2 crew will do
could potentially feed back into space
operations on the ground absolutely a
very full circle moment right there so
by the time we're launching ax3 we will
have those data back and we'll be ahead
of the game
so on the tech side of research being
conducted This Crew will also
demonstrate ways to automate some of the
tasks that take up precious crew time
things like transferring data or
tracking where supplies and materials
are on board the space station there's
also an effort to make communicating
with Earth easier
so at the heart of Axiom space is the
Mantra to build history to expand access
to low earth orbit for all and so we're
dedicated to creating Partnerships with
companies that you wouldn't typically
expect to hear about going to space to
grow the volume of those who can conduct
meaningful research and research on
board and Outreach as well about science
and everything else included in that so
a lot going on up there and they're
certainly going to hand their hands full
once they dock which we should be seeing
shortly here yeah we're very much
looking forward to it uh look at this
this is our first few inside the Dragon
capsule I love this view so on the left
hand side would be our commander Peggy
Whitson and on the right hand side of
that view was uh pilot John shoffner now
this view is also very cool because this
is looking at the International Space
Station from the Dragon
what a great shot yeah it's just
incredible that we can get these live
views and see what dragon is seeing as
it is as it is approaching the ISS
I love living in the future
[Laughter]
like we've mentioned before we are
heading to the node 2 Zenith Port this
morning
we have passed through Waypoint zero
which is the 400 meter Mark which is 400
meters away from station and we're
heading up and around over the station
to Waypoint one which is about Dragon
station on the big loop expect
reconfiguration of the c2v2 return link
shortly
make sure I can copy
station copies
so that was SpaceX core David Huang just
letting the crew know of this upcoming
event referring to c2v2 which is the
common communication for visiting
vehicle and that's basically just the
link for the visiting vehicle in this
case dragon freedom but yeah this view
is over the shoulders of our commander
and pilot and I love that you can see
what they're seeing
um in the center we can see that they
are following along with the upcoming
events the views on the far left and Far
Right panel
um will illustrate which thrusters are
firing when
um so I don't really see any oh we can
see some a little bit of light flashing
so if you look at the the far left panel
and the upper right hand corner we saw
um some illumination there indicating
that the Draco thrusters uh were firing
and one thing that I love about our
views as we get closer to the
International Space Station the views
that we will get from the ISS looking at
Dragon we should actually be able to see
those Draco thrusters firing as dragon
is autonomously steering itself toward
that Zenith port
now when we say autonomous it's truly
what that means dragon is doing all the
calculations and and and steering and
flying uh automatically it is flying
itself that being said
um our pilot John schoffner has the
capability to take over manual control
at any time if necessary
but it is
incredible to be able to see what
they're seeing Oh and that view on the
left hand side there we can actually see
those thrusters as I mentioned
it almost looks as if dragon is like
spitting out a little bit and uh it's
just really cool to be able to see uh
that propulsion system in action
as dragon is flying itself to that
Zenith port
and I love it with those two views that
we just had because it's Dragon looking
at station as well as station looking at
Dragon which always kind of reminds me
of the uh the Spider-Man meme of them
pointing at each other
it's a very meta moment
that image on the right you see our
commander piggy Whitson on the left
pilot John Shafter on the right and out
of frame our mission specialist Rihanna
Barney and Ali Al Carney
likely also monitoring all these events
everyone is everyone on board this
dragon is probably very very anxiously
awaiting this moment of docking
ending nearly a 16-hour transit to get
to the ISS after launching
now we are roughly 20 minutes away from
hitting that approach one uh or excuse
me that that Waypoint one uh which like
I mentioned before is 220 meters away
from the International Space Station
and we can see that the crew has their
visors up we don't require them to put
their visors down until they're closer
to the space station for that docking
procedure
so they're still hanging out
continuing to monitor dragon's progress
as we said before once the four Axiom II
crew members get on station
they're going to be there for eight days
and
they're going to be very busy
when you're on station your schedule is
packed with science and research
sleeping your sleep periods are are
scheduled to ensure that everybody's
getting appropriate rest your meal times
and then of course you have to build in
some exercise time as well
but yeah the crew will be uh very busy
once they get on station so these final
moments before they actually arrive
um might actually be very calm and
restful because like we said before the
the crew right now they are monitoring
they are keeping an eye on Dragon
systems uh and of course keeping in
contact with the integrated operations
teams from all three mission control
centers that we mentioned before
once again this is a live view of the
International Space Station from dragon
it almost looks fake
and so uh clear and beautiful
as we get closer you should be able to
make out more clearly the various
vehicles that are docked with the
International Space Station
once we get closer I definitely want to
keep an eye on to to those various ports
as we mentioned we did a port relocation
maneuver for the crew 6 capsule
um Dragon station on the big loop c2v2
link reconfiguration complete
CTV
as I mentioned we did a port relocation
maneuver for the crew 6 capsule which is
dragon in Denver it was relocated to the
node 2 forward port
and we should be able to see that as we
get closer
and I just love it when there is a
Dragon capsule getting a view of another
Dragon capsule that is on station we had
that view during the crew 6 stalking if
I remember correctly
so this is a live view coming to us from
the International Space Station to or of
dragon Freedom as it approaches
all right so as we are continuing to get
uh get closer to the International Space
Station we are heading towards that
Waypoint one let's check back in with
Leah over at Johnson Space Center to
hear how things are continuing to
progress with the International Space
Station's preparation for Dragon freedom
hi Kate Hi Duke thanks for carrying us
through a little bit of that and uh yes
that's no moon that is Dragon
approaching the International Space
Station as you heard we've reached
Waypoint zero that 400 meters away from
the space station we're just a little
bit below that now but as you can see
we've made quite a bit of movement our
recent our previous View of dragon had
the Earth in the background now we have
space in the background the spacecraft
has moved out in front of the
International Space Station still less
than 400 meters away about 380 meters
right now but we're moving up to
Waypoint one
and again Waypoint one is about 220
meters away from the space station it'll
be directly above that node 2 Zenith or
space-facing Port
we will we have the opportunity to pause
here check out any systems if needed and
we expect arrival at Waypoint one in
about 10 minutes
once Dragon reaches way point one the
next stop is Waypoint two that is only
20 meters away from the International
Space Station so that's when we hope to
get that Crystal Clear View of dragon
freedom and its four crew members inside
we do conduct a hold at Waypoint two
this is to make sure that we are
properly aligned with the docking Target
on node 2 also known as Harmony
after reaching Waypoint 2 dragon will
slowly but surely move in and dock with
that Port conducting a soft capture
first before the hooks begin to drive
and complete a hard capture then it
takes about two hours until dragon
hatches are ready to be opened and the
four new crew members make their way
aboard the space station
now 350 meters away from the station
again this is Dragon Freedom it was
named that by the crew 4 crew that
visited the International Space Station
spacecraft keep their names after being
named by the crew so this one will
always carry the name Freedom regardless
of who's flying on board
on the International Space Station side
things continue to move smoothly again
we have NASA astronaut Woody hoberg in
the cupola along with UAE astronaut
Sultan on the Yadi they're monitoring
dragon's approach it is a fully
autonomous flight for the visiting
spacecraft meaning there is no action
required on part of the crew however
they do have the ability to take control
if needed as well as the crew aboard the
space station can send commands to
Dragon to retreat if necessary but we're
not expecting any of that this morning
as things continue to move smoothly now
330 meters away from the orbiting
Laboratory
on the space station side the solar
arrays have been configured again teams
here in Mission Control Houston will
command the solar arrays into a position
we call it being feathered this keeps
any loads from being imparted on the
solar arrays themselves from any plumes
that come from dragon as it makes those
fine-tuned maneuvers
we are in a satellite Handover again
with the tracking data and relay
satellite systems but a great shot here
of Mission Control at SpaceX in
Hawthorne California
again we're in integrated operations now
that we are inside the approach
ellipsoid that four kilometer by two by
two kilometer invisible invisible oval
that helps us monitor all of the
arriving and departing spacecraft at the
International Space Station
and on the right hand side of your
screen you've got Mission Control
Houston
these teams work around the clock 24 7
to monitor all of the station systems
leading the teams this morning is flight
director Marcos Flores
and communicating with the astronauts
aboard the International Space Station
is Capcom or capsule Communicator Justin
cartilage
on the left now you can see the Axiom
space flight control room they are
monitoring the flight as well they'll
remain on Console this week to help the
crew members execute all of the research
and the payload work that they have
planned additionally they'll be
conducting several downlink events with
various media and other stem
organizations here on Earth
now just 290 meters away from the space
station and closing in again slow and
steady we are less than one mile per
hour as we see crew Dragon move toward
the International Space Station Zenith
port
once we reach that it'll be Waypoint one
we hope to see that in about five
minutes and we're tracking docking again
this morning at 8 10 a.m central time so
just about 20 minutes from now
so look back at what has brought Dragon
to this point uh less than an hour after
liftoff last night at about 5 23 PM
Central Time Dragon executed the phase
burn this was the first of those five
major Burns this raised dragon's orbit
using the Draco thrusters and about
seven hours later we had the Boost burn
this put our crew in an orbit where
dragon's apogee or the highest point of
its orbit around the Earth is 10
kilometers lower than the space station
after that we execute the close Co
elliptic burn and this puts dragon on an
orbit roughly co-eleptic with the
station so it means it maintains that
orbit about 10 kilometers lower than the
station all the way around instead of
just at apogee
the transfer burn occur occurred at
about 2 47 a.m this morning Central Time
this is where we raise dragon's apogee
again that's the highest point of its
orbit to just 2.5 kilometers lower than
the station we want to make that
co-eleptic one more time so we round
that out with the final Co elliptic burn
that was at 3 34 a.m Central this
morning maintaining the constant orbit
about 2.5 kilometers below the station
we also saw the approach initiation burn
just at the start of today's broadcast
this really begins the final stages of
dragon's rendezvous with the station and
we started integrated operations between
the dragon control team in Hawthorne and
the space station flight controllers
here in Mission Control Houston
this approach initiation brought us up
to Waypoint zero Waypoint zero is 400
meters below the station this is the
first checkpoint during the approach we
have now entered the approach ellipsoid
that first boundary of monitoring the uh
arrival and departure of visiting
vehicles of course we didn't even have
to hold it at that 400 meters all of the
systems checked out and dragon has
continued its approach to Waypoint one
this happens when we are about 220
meters away from the space station we're
currently 240 meters away so we're
getting very close and not 220 meters at
Waypoint one puts us on the docking axis
meaning it's directly above the docking
port so we're heading toward the Zenith
Port of the International Space
Station's node 2 module also known as
Harmony
currently docked to the forward Port we
have uh dragon Endeavor which brought
the crew 6 crew
so once dragon is only 20 meters on the
big loop approach one and soft capture
ring extension will begin shortly Dragon
will continue approach to Waypoint two
reminder that manual impulsive Retreat
recovery is not permitted
happy
education copies
and confirmation that the spacecraft has
arrived at Waypoint one again we have
the opportunity to hold here it's 220
meters away from the International Space
Station specifically in line with the
docking axis on the uh Zenith Port of
node 2.
and you can see some of those Thruster
plumes coming from again as it
fine-tunes its approach using those
service section Draco thrusters
a great view of those thrusters firing
on dragon as we are at Waypoint one 220
meters away from the International Space
Station specifically directly above the
space station an inside Dragon right now
we have our four private astronauts uh
Peggy Whitson the commander pilot John
schoffner Brown abanawi
with you on the big loop
at price range 208 meters and decreasing
attitude as expected
we copy and concur from the ground
beautiful view
for a moment there we
have a dragon this courtesy of Cronus uh
Cronus flight controller here this
morning is Brian crisp in Mission
Control Houston
dragons thrusters continue to fire we
are now less than 200 meters away from
the space station we have passed through
Waypoint one as well as the keep out
sphere and the keepout sphere is that
200 meter radius around the
International Space Station another
invisible boundary that helped us
monitor our arriving and departing
vehicles
the next pause for Dragon will be at
Waypoint two this is a hold Point that's
the 20 meters away from the
International Space Station when we move
in toward final docking
in this view of dragon Freedom you can
see the hatch or the nose cone is opened
and a good view of those four forward
bulkhead thrusters those are used for
the larger Burns we are now using the 12
service section Draco thrusters
these are for more fine-tooed fine-tuned
attitude Maneuvers especially as we get
closer to the International Space
Station the nose cone protects those
thrusters as well as the docking
mechanisms aboard dragon
we're expecting arrival at Waypoint two
in about eight minutes and again looking
for docking this morning at
approximately 8 10 a.m Central Time
Dragon freedom is now 164 meters away
from the International Space Station so
while we are moving less than one mile
per hour we are continuing to close in
on the destination for the 8x2 crew
it's like dragon on the big blue
copy Dragon visas are closed
as we've mentioned earlier the
ax2 crew are in their suits and in their
seats we got that view over their
shoulders this morning
they do not have to wear their suits for
the entirety of the flight when they are
not in these Dynamic operations periods
they are welcome to take those out take
those off and get into some more
comfortable attire specifically for
their sleep portion of their flight
however now they are in their suits
they've conducted suit leak checks
through the umbilicals that connect to
the spacecraft itself these also provide
Communications and cooling for the
astronauts
and as you heard Commander Peggy Whitson
just report down to the ground the
visors have been closed on the suit so
they are preparing for docking and again
we're looking for that about 10 minutes
from now we do have some time and some
hold time that we can conduct at
Waypoint two if needed we can wait until
lighting conditions are preferred for
Dragon to move in for its final docking
once dragon flies in and makes contact
with the international docking adapter
we will have soft capture this is when
the soft capture ring retracts and
sensors will indicate it's time for 12
hooks to drive in place once those hooks
have fully driven we'll have hard
capture and that firmly secures Dragon
to its new home on the space station
now just 130 meters from the
International Space Station everything
continuing to move smoothly for Dragon
Bar review of steps five and six is
complete and ISS is ready for docking
Houston copies
station Houston on the big loop at
Waypoint two dragon will briefly pause
to align for docking then automatically
resume approach
we are less than 100 meters from the
International Space Station
currently flight director Marcus Flores
here in Mission Control Houston is
polling all of the team members in this
room
conducting their go no go Poll for
docking
just heard confirmations
for Final Approach ground has pulled go
for approach two and we'll be commanding
approach allowed shortly as a reminder
that once dragon is inside the crew
hands-off Point Retreat and breakout are
not permitted
[Music]
two hands off point
patient crew copies and we are ready for
Final Approach
a lot of voices in the mix there the
last one being from NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg who's in the cupola monitoring
docking this morning
and good words from all of the teams
that they are go for docking
dragon is now less than 60 meters away
from the International Space Station we
are expecting arrival at Waypoint two in
two minutes again that'll be the 20
meters away from the International Space
Station directly above the node 2 Zenith
docking act or docking port
we do have a pause at Waypoint too and
they can hold there for an extended
period of time if need be if they want
to wait for lighting conditions to
change in order to check out systems any
further however things continuing to
look good this morning
currently the International Space
Station and dragon are flying 262
statute miles over Russia in an orbital
night time
dragon now 34 meters away from the
International Space Station we also
heard confirmation earlier from teams
here on the ground that the soft capture
ring is properly extended this will be
the first step in the docking process
Dragon will make contact with the
International Space Station and that
docking ring or the soft capture ring
will retract pulling it in until it's
time for the two sets of six hooks so 12
hooks in total to make the hard capture
to the International Space Station
standing by for arrival at Waypoint two
teams here are all on the ground are all
go for docking as well as aboard the
International Space Station and dragon
itself again this graphic just to look
at what we have seen so far uh most
recently this morning when Dragon
arrived at Waypoint zero 400 meters away
from the space station moving into
Waypoint one 220 meters directly above
and on the docking axis we have now
moved down from that 220 meters into
just 220 meters from the International
Space Station directly above the Note 2
Zenith port
this is a whole point on the big loop
dragon is on Final Approach and is go
for
go from zero two dragon approach and
Retreat monitoring
station copies didn't work
again we do not have video feed from the
International Space Station or Dragon at
this time but
teams continue to monitor its approach
to the space station itself we have now
left that Waypoint to hold point of 20
meters away now about 16 meters from the
International Space Station
Dragon freedom and the ax2 crew now
moving at 0.2 miles per hour
all four crew members suited and in
their seats preparing for docking
The Neighbors
copy 10 meters
as you can hear the dragon crew are able
to view the status of they are docking
on the crew display screens
reporting that they are now 10 meters
and actually less than 10 meters away
from the node 2 Zenith or space-facing
port on the International Space Station
five meters
probably five meters
still moving 0.2 miles per hour Dragon
freedom is now five meters away from the
International Space Station again we do
not have video feed of the spacecraft at
this time but team members are able to
track its status and everything
continues to go as planned
the crew is now three meters from the
space station
meters top
copy two meters
chop stands for the crew hands-off point
now two meters from the station standing
by for doctor
copy one meter
soft capture confirmed
and we have confirmation that the Axiom
2 crew has docked to the International
Space Station
Central Time
that's all capture ring now beginning to
retract and pull dragon in toward the
International Space Station
docking coming as the space station
itself was flying 262 statute miles
Northeast of Japan
and correction on last we're still
waiting on attenuation
continuing to get good reports here from
teams on the ground again aboard the
International Space Station NASA's Woody
hoberg and uae's Sultan al-nayadi
continued to monitor the crew as well
after soft capture is complete those 12
hooks will begin to drive and pull
Dragon securely
firmly securing it to the node 2 Zenith
port
and dragon now we have ring retraction
in progress
Ive
stocking I've ever had
good words from commander of the ax2
mission former NASA astronaut Peggy
Whitson now flying her third spacecraft
after having flown the space shuttle
arrest Cosmos soyuz and now a SpaceX
dragon
that soft capture ring continues to
retract again this is the first stage in
docking shortly after ring retraction is
complete we will move into the hard
docking portion this is when those 12
hooks two sets of six drive and firmly
secure the spacecraft to the node two
Zenith Port again just a few weeks ago
the node 2 Xena Port was occupied by
another SpaceX dragon dragon was
relocated by the crew 6 crew who arrived
on that spacecraft from the forward port
or from the Zenith Port where uh dragon
Freedom now is to the forward port
again we expect the Axiom 2 crew to live
and work aboard the International Space
Station for about eight days before
beginning their return journey to Earth
ring retraction complete talking
sequence is holding for MCs
reconfiguration
we have confirmation that the ring
retraction is complete
next steps for this hard capture will be
for those 12 hooks to drive
and in addition to the ring retraction
in these hooks driving and umbilical
will also be connected from dragon to
the International Space Station this
will allow power to flow from the space
station to Dragon itself so that dragon
is no longer relying on battery power uh
that power being gathered from the solar
cells around the base of its trunk
again we are in a Handover of our
satellites for KU which is what brings
down our video we do have audio
communication with the crew through our
s-band
MCS configured proceeding with hook
driving
change reporting that we are properly
configured for hard capture again this
is 12 hooks two sets of six they will
drive the first six uh and those are
firmly latched they will then drive the
next six we do see those first six hooks
now starting to drive
the first six hooks continue to drive in
the hard capture process again after
these we'll have another set of six
before we can officially declare that
dragon is firmly secured to the
International Space Station everything
continuing to go as planned this morning
again docking coming at 8 12 a.m at
Central Time
we have confirmation that the first set
of six hooks have now closed and the
second set are driving
again this view from Mission Control
Houston as teams are monitoring the
docking of dragon freedom to the uh no
teasing basis on behalf of the
Expedition 6 crew taking Peggy welcome
back John welcome to the International
Space Station and Ali and Rihanna
we're really looking forward to working
with you guys this week
likewise we'll see you guys very soon
and we have confirmation the second set
of hooks has closed from dragon on the
International Space Station meaning hard
capture is complete
thank you
Dragon station hardcaptor complete
and what's that called
hard capture is complete dragon is
firmly attached to the International
Space Station it's home for at least the
next eight days
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg on the space
station side will now move into
preparing uh the hatches for opening
again that takes about a two hour
process the vestibule needs to be
pressurized the area in between the
space station and dragon
coming up the ax2 crew will have the
chance to doff or take off their
spacesuits maybe get into their flight
suits before they float aboard and we
begin our welcome ceremony
and Dragon SpaceX docking sequence
complete crew Dragon Freedom Peggy John
Ali Ray congrats on this historic
achievement welcome to the International
Space Station
it was a lovely ride and as I mentioned
it was a fox
very well done thanks to everyone for
getting us to start
thanks Peggy we do aim for excellence
and on behalf of SpaceX it's been a
pleasure working with you and just a
little bit of trivia for you this was
the fastest launch to dark time for a
crew Dragon beating our previous record
from crew 4 by just nine minutes ground
will be enabling Heartland power and
calm connection shortly and you are good
seats per procedure for decimal zero one
two ground will be taking cameras
external
0012 and work
dragging on dragging the ground no
response required cameras are external
now that all the hooks have driven and
the soft capture ring has been stowed
docking is officially complete the crew
is go to doff their suits that's why the
teams on the ground have told them that
the cameras are
not live at this time inside the cabin
again we still do not have a video from
the International Space Station at this
time it looks like we'll regain shortly
the space station itself is in an
orbital nighttime
now flying 261 statute miles over the
Pacific Ocean
again docking this morning at 8 12 a.m
Central Time as noted by SpaceX the
fastest docking on record for a crew
launch to the International Space
Station on Dragon
we also have confirmation that the
umbilicals have attached from dragon to
the International Space Station again
these allow power to flow from the space
station to dragon as well as data and
other telemetry
when in Free Flight Dragon uses power
gained from its solar arrays and is
stored and used from batteries aboard
the spacecraft so connecting to these
umbilicals allows it to rely on power
generated from the space station
we'll stay live now that we have docked
until our welcome ceremony standing by
for the start time for the ceremony
but this hatch open process takes about
two hours
a look ahead at the steps that we'll be
happening over the next couple of hours
again Woody hoberg NASA astronaut on
expectation is prime for these
operations and bringing the ax2 crew on
board
now that we're docked he is securing
some hardware and then we'll move into
Hatch operations first he will open the
large hatch at node 2 Zenith that'll
give him access inside the pressurized
meeting adapter he will then help
pressurize the vestibule that's again
the small space between the hatches on
dragon and the space station of course
this was previously exposed to a vacuum
prior to docking we need to fill it with
air make sure its pressure is nearly
equal with the atmosphere pressures on
driving in the station
and Dragon SpaceX I had you five by five
on the cabin mic but I am seeing that
you have both ground and ISS set to PTT
please set it to only the big loop
okay
and I have you five by five homie
thanks
to station on two for pma3 Ingress part
step one
Houston is with you on too
all right just looking for your go
instead of one decimal one
standby one and we are checking on that
now
Jason copies
as you heard teams on the ground
communicating
with the crew still aboard Dragon
freedom
Peggy Woodson took a chance to test out
the cabin mic rather than the
microphones they'd been using anyways
a procedure two decimal one zero two
if you go in step one decimal one of two
decimal one zero two
and that voice being uh NASA astronaut
Woody hoberg communicating with
Justin
cartilage here on the ground his Capcom
the capsule Communicator that's the
person speaking with the astronauts
aboard the International Space Station
Woody is now stepping through some
procedures including
um he will get access inside the
pressurized mating adapter and then
pressurize the vestibule we want to make
sure the pressure is almost equal with
the pressures on board dragon and the
station
he'll use a small valve on the station's
hatch to slowly introduce air into the
vestibule fly controllers here in
Houston will monitor the pressure and
temperature readings inside and verify
that everything is leak free before we
get ready to open the hatches
again it's about a two hour process to
get everything pressurized and checked
out before we open the hatches
and following that hatch open will have
a welcoming ceremony with all four ax2
astronauts as well as our seven crew
members living aboard the station so if
it's not too early for you to do some
math yes that is 11 people that'll be
living aboard the International Space
Station for at least the next week
Houston copies
again we are
live covering the arrival of the ax2
crew to the International Space Station
this is the second private astronaut
mission that has visited the
International Space Station following
Axiom one flight last year
our crew members aboard Dragon Freedom
today include Commander former NASA
astronaut Peggy Whitson
up until now she has spent 665 days in
space so she's looking to add to that
total it's more than any us astronaut
and more than any woman in the world
she's joined by Pilot John schoffner
and the two Mission Specialists
representing the Saudi space commission
are Ali alkarni and Rihanna barnawi
station on two we're ready for step two
decimal two on your go
checking
here we go with two decimal two
go
we hear NASA astronaut Woody hoberg
stepping through the procedures with the
grounds go uh he will begin pressurizing
the vestibule shortly
in the meantime NASA astronaut Frank
Rubio continues to conduct some Hardware
servicing on the space station 56 on the
big loop if desired reference procedure
of 4 decimal 400 for monitoring
vestibule pressurization
confirmation from teams on the ground
that vestibule pressurization has begun
again this is the small space between
the uh the dragon hatch and the space
station hatch we want to bring that up
from vacuum to about 14.7 PSI that's
about the same pressure as the
International Space Station
approximately the same pressure we're
used to here on Earth
astronauts on the space station live in
a mixed nitrogen oxygen environment
again very similar to what we have on
Earth
and dragon station on the big loop no
response required ISS power connection
established
it's a station on two step two decimal
four a pass pressure equalized at 1339
GMT
Eastern copies 1339 GMT
you can see some movement
[Music]
um
and we have our view back of
dragon
as we see a sunrise in the background
this view of dragon Freedom with the ax2
crew aboard docked to the node 2 Zenith
port on the International Space Station
again that docking coming at 8 12 a.m
Central Time
the crew inside are now out of their
suits they are preparing for Ingress to
the International Space Station again
this is a process though so we are
pressurizing the vestibule the space
between the two spacecraft and if you
see some color changes that's because
the International Space Station and
dragon are not flying into an orbital
Sunrise they are 268 statute miles over
the South Pacific Ocean
now that they're docked these two will
travel 17 500 miles per hour together
seeing 16 sunrises and sunsets a day so
the ax2 crew is certainly in for a treat
for their planned eight-day stay
here in Mission Control Houston teams
are handing over from the orbit one
shift to the orbit 2 Shift we have had
Marcus Flores as our flight director
this morning he will be handing over to
Vincent LaPorte
again Woody hoberg aboard the
International Space Station is leading
the team's Freedom Houston stand by for
Hardline
online
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg working to
pressurize the vestibule the space
between the hatches
again this takes about an two hours
before the crew members float aboard the
International Space Station all four
Axiom 2 crew members still in Dragon
Freedom as you see there docked to the
node two Zenith port
once they float aboard they will conduct
a welcome ceremony with all crew members
before heading into a safety briefing
these private astronauts trained for
many uh contingency scenarios down here
on the ground but the teams aboard the
International Space Station will help
show them different locations and
procedures now that they are on orbit
later today the dragon Freedom crew will
work to transfer some go from dragon to
the International Space Station that
includes some of the scientific research
they'll be doing this week as well as
Hardware or food needed
Freedom Houston on the big loop for a
Comcheck Hardline audio configuration is
complete
region has 11 clear on the big new card
line
good news
and Dragon SpaceX on the big loop
permission to come on board with cameras
okay come on board now but we'll
probably have to ask you to go away
again in a little bit
welcome aboard
copy that uh we'll keep them exterior
until you're ready
okay thank you
recently you heard a call from
Mission Control in Hawthorne at SpaceX
headquarters check in with the crew to
see if they could turn cameras on on the
spacecraft they'll hold off for a little
bit longer on that
but we still have all four crew members
aboard
it has now been uh 41 minutes since they
docked to the node 2 Zenith Port making
their official arrival at the
International Space Station
on the space station side
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg is preparing
the
apas hatch for opening
and SpaceX drag in on the big loop just
to let you know we've got all four four
suits drawing the shortest timer is uh
passing seven minutes right now
copy all four suits drawing and seven
minutes have elapsed
and dragon with suits drying I can give
you a go for sections one through three
of four decimal 400.
happy one two three a four decimal 400.
again you're watching live coverage of
the ax2 crew arrival at the
International Space Station the crew
docked Dragon freedom to the node 2
zenith-facing Port this morning at 8 12
a.m Central Time
and water inventory
copy that ring read copy for inventory
207 four bottles
305 one meal and a snap 2015 one meal in
a stock
307 one meal on this March 315 one meal
and a second
copy that and to read back we have five
bottles from 203 four bottles from 207
one meal and one snack from locations
three zero five three one three three
zero seven and three one five
thank you
as you just heard
Saudi space commission astronaut Rihanna
bernawi reporting out the inventory
aboard crew dragon
everything is meticulously tracked
aboard the space station and dragon as
well so she was reporting which meals
and snacks had been consumed during
their 16 approximate 16-hour flight from
uh launch last night at 5 37 PM Eastern
Time to docking this morning at 9 12 a.m
Eastern Time
again you're watching live coverage of
the ax2 arrival at the International
Space Station the second private
astronaut mission to visit the space
station following the Axiom one flight
last year
currently aboard Dragon Freedom which
you see on your screen attached to the
station's node 2 Zenith Port our
commander Peggy Whitson pilot John
schoffner and Mission Specialists Ali
alcarney and Rihanna barnawi
on the space station NASA astronaut
Woody hoberg is working to pressurize
the C6 on the big loop for procedure for
decimal 400.
go for four decimal 400.
hey so we're getting close to finishing
the leak check but you have a go to
perform section five for the dock waste
system configuration
okay go for Section Five we'll try and
get all the other activities out of the
way first and get that in March
we heard Peggy Whitson earlier say that
the crew has doffed their suits they are
now in probably their flight suits ahead
of heading into the International Space
Station we're expecting that around 10
a.m central time for those hatches to
open they are drying their suits
currently
just keeping them in good shape ahead of
a trip home they're planning on about an
eight day stay aboard the International
Space Station however several things can
affect that departure date mainly the
weather at the landing locations SpaceX
has a number of Select landing locations
off the coast of Florida
and we watch for things like wave height
or wave Cadence as well as wind speeds
to ensure that the crew have the safest
and most comfortable Landing possible
station Houston on the Loop we have a
good leak check ISS go to complete
vestibule Equalization and open the apas
hatch at step 3 decimal one a procedure
two decimal one zero two
PlayStation copies go in three decimal
one
for those of you just joining our
coverage of Axiom 2 uh crew in our
SpaceX Dragon Freedom capsule which is
what you see there on your screen has
successfully docked to the International
Space Station in fact we had a new
record time for SpaceX operations we
actually beat the crew 4 record from
liftoff to soft capture our record time
now is about 15 hours and 35 minutes
from liftoff to soft capture so
basically the most efficient and fastest
transit to the International Space
Station from pad 39a that's a beautiful
view there of that Dragon Freedom
capsule this is docked at the node 2
Zenith port
the crew 6 capsule until about a couple
weeks ago was docked to this same port
and we did a port relocation maneuver
with the crew 6 crew to move it down to
the node 2 forward port
by doing so we were able to clear this
Zenith port for the ax2 mission as well
as the upcoming crs-28 cargo resupply
mission
although it might look stagnant if you
look at it quickly
you can't see planet Earth
rotating slowly behind or rather under
the Dragon capsule and the International
Space Station
there at the bottom of the screen you
can
kind of make out the Canada arm
which is the robotic arm that the crew
onboard station will utilize in order to
remove cargo from the unpressurized
section of dragon located in the trunk
which is essentially the
top half in this orientation the top
half of the Dragon capsule of course
when we are sitting at the launch pad or
other conventional views of dragons the
bottom half
but really it's that half black half
white cylindrical portion of dragon that
we see there
this view is also great because you get
a really clear view of the nose cone and
all of the hardware that the nose cone
protects during the uh the launch phase
of course we got some ambient noise here
at SpaceX headquarters as our first
shift operations are well underway
all right
during the ascent phase that nose cone
will be closed and that protects the
forward hatch as well as the forward
bulkhead Draco thrusters
foreign
so right now the Axiom 2 crew they have
taken their suits off we heard the call
out earlier that the suits are drying
and as you can see the Dragon capsule
is docked and
um they have completed pressurization of
the uh the apas hatch so we uh are
making great progress
um but talking about the crew let's get
to learn a little bit more about them in
case you may have missed our
introductions earlier in the broadcast
as we've been we've been going for a
little bit while so let's learn more
about more about the ax2 crew yeah it's
always good to get a little refresher on
our ax2 crew here the ax2 mission is
commanded by retired NASA astronaut
Peggy Whitson born and raised in
Beaconsfield Iowa she was inspired along
with the world when she watched the
Apollo 11 crew walk on the moon she has
since become the most experienced
American astronaut and one of the most
decorated Whitson flew three long
duration missions to the ISS and has
more cumulative time in space 665 days
than any U.S astronaut and more than any
woman in the world she has conducted 10
spacewalks with over 60 hours of time
and has performed hundreds of research
experiments on board the ISS
not only is she the commander for this
Mission but Peggy also serves as the
Director of human space play for Axiom
space
the pilot for ax2 is private Astronaut
John schoffner born in Alaska and raised
in Kentucky shafner is a steam education
Advocate business Pioneer and lifelong
space Enthusiast a pilot since the age
of 17 John has over 8 500 flight hours
holding commercial instrument single
engine and multi-engine ratings and land
and sea aircraft as well as helicopter
he also holds ratings in former military
jets and high performance radial engine
aircraft as an athlete John has years of
exp years of competitive experience in
water skiing cycling White Water
kayaking hand gliding skydiving and base
jumping
John trained as the ax1 backup pilot and
during this mission on ax2 plans to
invest a lot of his time in Steam
education activities aimed at empowering
Educators and inspiring teachers
and representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as a mission
specialist Ali al-karni was born in
March 1992 in soft alalea Saudi Arabia
Ali is fluent in English as well as his
native Arabic and as an Air Force
Captain has 12 years of experience
flying on multiple aircraft primarily on
the f-15sa in service to the Royal Saudi
Air Force Ali graduated with a bachelor
of Aerospace science degree in 2013 from
King Faisal Air Academy in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia
also representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as a mission
specialist Rihanna Barney or as we hear
her identify herself as Ray on comms was
born in September 1988 and Jeddah Saudi
Arabia
has a master's degree in biomedical
Sciences from alphaisal University in
Riyadh Saudi Arabia and a bachelor's
degree in biomedical Sciences from otago
University in Dunedin New Zealand she is
fluent in English and Turkish as well as
native Arabic she has been a research
lab technician since 2013 in the stem
cell and tissue re-engineering program
at King Faisal Specialist Hospital and
research center and located in Riyadh
Saudi Arabia
and there they are the ax2 crew we are
so excited for them to now be docked to
the ISS and so proud that they've made
it this far after all their training
this is a really wonderful moment to be
celebrating their journey to space yeah
obviously Peggy
um a NASA Legend has spent years
training to go to space our three
formerly spaced newbies now that they
are up there and now docked the
International Space Station can't really
call them rookies anymore but yeah all
four of them have been training
extensively for this Mission and it's so
great to see that they get to use it now
yeah yes absolutely and on those uh on
those cards you may have seen their
patch on their flight suits and since
the beginning of the Space Race in the
1960s a custom patch has been used to
represent and identify individual
missions and their Crews it's also a
long-held custom that these Crews
influence or even outright design their
own patches injecting them with
symbolism and personal elements to
commemorate their Journey This Crew has
continued this long-standing tradition
with their official ax2 mission patch so
let's take a look
the X2 Mission patch highlights the
beauty of space hope for the future
attaches open with negative condensation
oh
that is great news
sounds like a hatch open update
okay continuing on this patch
this patch highlights the beauty of
space hope for the future and the
important role of the ISS to unite the
best aspects of humanity
shown prominently are the mission name
ax2 the family names of the crew members
and the flags of the United States and
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia the two
Nations represented on board today's
flight
there are five shapes drawn as
constellations and these represent the
crew's intention to focus on inspiration
education and teaching through Steam
education initiatives
and so there's a constellation for
science technology engineering arts and
math
the arched path leading from Earth to
space is colored lavender which is
culturally significant in the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia symbolizing hospitality
that arched path and color also reflect
ksa's desire to be part of the space
sector and position itself as a
contributor to the global space
community
then naturally the space station is
Central to the image as the destination
of This Crew while Earth is featured
with prominent Horizon Lines symbolizing
optimism hope and inspiration
just as you see this Mission patch worn
by the crew on their flight suits is
patches currently adoring the walls of
Axiom space's Mission Control in Houston
and is placed into position of Honor
everywhere This Crew is being supported
for the duration of their mission
as someone that is an engineer but I
have a background in music and theater
and art I you know have a personal
appreciation for just how evident and
apparent the emphasis on Steam you know
science technology engineering Arts
mathematics it's been a long morning I
think I got those letters in the right
order
um but yeah it's so great to see all
that represented so strongly on the ax2
mission patch I just I love it it's one
of my favorite Mission patches that that
we've had
now let's turn it back over to NASA's
Leah Cheshire who is standing by at
Mission Control Center at the Johnson
Space Center in Houston Texas for an
update on Space Station operations
Leah
thanks Kate and Duke yes we are still
here in International Space Station
flight control room at Johnson Space
Center in Houston Texas continuing to
monitor the arrival of the ax2 crew and
their eventual uh welcome to the
International Space Station again we
docked at 8 12 a.m central time this
morning so a little over an hour ago to
the node 2 Zenith or space facing Port
which is where you see the crew now they
are flying over the country of Chad 256
miles above Earth and those calls you
heard about the hatch those are
those are the a-pass hatch and the
vestibule hatch NASA astronaut Woody
hoberg is stepping through hatch
procedures this morning he's currently
in the a-pass hatch and I looked it up
to make sure to get it right for all of
you a pass stands for androgynous
peripheral assembly system
I think it's pretty clear why we call it
a pass keep it short and sweet but that
hatch has been opened he is inside and
he is also has also opened the vestibule
hatch so the dragon hatch is not open
yet we've still got some things that we
need to work through on the SpaceX side
as well as on the NASA side to make sure
that we're ready to welcome the ax2 crew
members aboard
after after launch yesterday at 5 37 PM
Eastern Time made its way to the
International Space Station conducting a
series of Burns and checkpoints along
the way
this view inside the International Space
Station you're getting a look at Nasa
astronaut Woody hoberg this is his first
flight to the space station he arrived
as a member of crew six clear this year
he is preparing the space station for
entry of the ax2 crew as you can see
he's working on some venting that tube
will go from the space station into
dragon and kind of help equalize the
um and balance out the air and the mix
of the air that's in the space station
to what's currently in Dragon
again the dragon hatch is not open yet
we are remaining live all the way
through their welcome ceremony when we
see the four crew members Peggy wits and
John schoffner the all Carney and
Rihanna barnawi float aboard the
International Space Station for the
start of their approximately eight day
stay
while aboard the space station the ax2
crew members are going to conduct a
plethora of scientific research as well
as conduct steam Outreach with students
and other
educational organizations here on Earth
and again they dock to the node 2 Zenith
Port this is where the crew 6 Dragon
known as Endeavor was docked just a few
weeks ago however it was moved from one
attached to the next so um Equalization
Houston copies on the big loop standby
for Equalization expect to take three
minutes additionally ground is a little
bit behind on configurations so expect a
slight delay for hatch opening
station copies
as NASA astronaut Woody hoberg gets
things ready on the station side the ax2
crew is still aboard dragon and they
continue to have some steps that they're
working through as well we heard Peggy
Whitson discuss the suit drawing that's
going on as well as Rana barnawi
reported down some of the consumables
that had been used during the flight
including meals that were eaten
everything is meticulously tracked of
word dragon as well as aboard the
International Space Station to make sure
that it can be accessed when needed
but we are moving along pretty smoothly
this morning toward hatch opening
International Space Station uses GMT as
their time zone so it's about 2 30 2 28
PM Pacific or sorry to be specific
aboard the International Space Station
right now so crew members are in the
middle of their works
complete configuration
five complete any Deltas to inventory
looking at our timeline some of the crew
members on the space station side are
enjoying their midday meal
of course after floating aboard we'll
see the ax2 crew move into their welcome
ceremony where they get to spend a
little time with the other seven crew
members on the International Space
Station and discuss their initial
reactions to being on orbit and visiting
the orbiting laboratory afterward
they'll step into their safety briefing
and make sure that everyone is aware of
the location of any certain safety items
aboard the International Space Station
as well as what to do in any event of a
contingency
after the safety briefing the crew draw
or the dragon Freedom astronauts uh the
ax2 crew will begin moving
some of the cargo from Dragon into the
International Space Station side
station Dragon Houston on the big loop
big picture update uh based on what we
see for open ground and crew actions we
see that we're about 15 minutes out from
hatch opening
Dragon copy 15 minutes out
presentation puppies one five minutes
teams on the ground and teams on the
space station continuing to step through
their procedures uh working toward hatch
opening in approximately 15 minutes
go ahead
um
hey was just wondering uh do we have a
change to inventory due to the waste
system flush
yeah to our inventory for water bottles
consumed
uh no we actually planned for the change
in inventory but since then I pulled out
one more bottle out of the same bag in
nine that still had bottles left
actually make it two more John wants to
grab one too
and copy that uh that's two bottles from
which location
copy that two bottles from two zero four
and uh just checking in are we able to
come back on board with cameras
copy that
we're about 10 minutes away from Dragon
hatch opening
International Space Station and dragon
are 261 statute miles over Kazakhstan
about to enter into an orbital night
time again we see 16 sunrises and
sunsets a day so I've been anticipating
another one of those in just a few
minutes you'll see some of the lighting
change if we have views outside of the
spacecraft
but again we are tracking about 9 45 a.m
central time for Dragon hatch opening
we'll see the ax2 crew members float
into the capsule and then begin the
welcome ceremony
again we are in a teacher's Handover
meaning we do not have Ku band that is
the antenna we use to bring down our
video from the International Space
Station so we are anticipating the crew
to float through the dragon hatch at
about 9 45 a.m central time we
anticipate having good video at that
time so we'll get to welcome those four
crew members aboard and see their
smiling faces now that they've arrived
at the space station
copy that Peggy bringing cameras back on
board
now first two suits to drive but we're
just gonna hold on packing them until
after the event if that sounds right to
you
yeah copy that Peggy um we'd recommend
opening the hatch first and then
possibly taking uh completing the tasks
first throwing the seats before
ingressing into ISS
okay Kathy will do
this is a view of Mission Control space
at SpaceX in Hawthorne California these
teams have been monitoring the flight of
dragon Freedom since launch yesterday
afternoon actually before launch
yesterday afternoon uh that launch come
at 5 37 PM eastern time from Florida and
Flawless launch and then about a 16-hour
Rendezvous to the International Space
Station we got into integrated
operations earlier this morning once we
crossed through the approach ellipsoid a
4x2 by 2 kilometer invisible boundary
around the space station that helped us
govern visiting spacecraft and their
arrival and departure
teams here in Michigan control Houston
now on your screen are being led by
Vincent lacorte flight director
they're working with astronauts aboard
the International Space Station and
staff this room 24 7 365 to ensure that
those astronauts and the space station
systems remain supported
we've had continuous presence aboard the
International Space Station for over 23
years now
and we'll be welcoming four crew members
shortly as part of the ax2 mission
the second private astronaut mission to
the International Space Station this
view coming from their mission control
also here in Houston Texas they'll
remain on Console all week to monitor
the status of the astronauts as well as
help them step through their research
payloads and any downlink opportunities
that they have
and we're expecting to regain Video
Communications with the space station
and dragon shortly
just a few moments from now we'll see
the ax2 crew float through the hatch and
bring our total of crew members living
on the space station to 11.
everything looking good ahead of hatch
opening on both sides the station and
dragon
we're just standing by to regain Video
Communications before we go for that
hatch open so we can ensure we'll see
The Smiling Faces of our four new crew
members joining the Expedition 69 crew
on the International Space Station again
we expect them to stay for about a week
before returning on Dragon Freedom back
to Earth
in Dragon SpaceX on the big loop s-span
will be deactivated shortly dragging the
ground will no longer be available for
comms please verify PTT destinations are
set to ISS
welcome
teams in Hawthorne speaking with the
crews still aboard Dragon Freedom
letting them know that uh shortly they
will not have the ability to communicate
from or through the dragon to ground
Loop itself however they will start
using the loops aboard the International
Space Station to talk with teams here in
Mission Control Houston as well as in
Hawthorne
again we are getting close to hatch
opening docking this morning occurring
at 8 12 a.m central time so about an
hour and a half ago it was a very smooth
ride to orbit yesterday launching at 5
37 PM eastern time and then again about
a 16 hour Transit the fastest on record
for a dragon crew to the International
Space Station
take a look inside Dragon Freedom as the
crew members
we have all this
all this is zero decimal
one copy all Peggy four decimal zero one
two complete
again this view of the crew inside
Dragon Freedom our four astronauts who
have arrived as part of Axiom mission 2
the second private mission to the
International Space Station up in the
center of the screen uh still sort of in
her seat that's uh former NASA astronaut
Peggy Whitson the commander of This Crew
over near the window you can see Ali
al-karni representing the Saudi space
commission down below him holding on to
one of the foot rests is John schoffner
the pilot and just off camera you can
see her hand right now that's Rihanna
bernawi also representing the Saudi
space commission we are standing by for
hatch opening of dragon freedom
again you're looking live inside Dragon
Freedom as we prepare for the hatch to
be opened and these four crew members to
float into the International Space
Station on what is the second private
astronaut mission to the orbiting
laboratory they will remain at the space
station for about eight days before
undocking and returning to Earth while
they're on board we will have a total of
11 people living and working aboard the
space station
again this crew launched at 5 37 PM
eastern time yesterday docking this
morning at 9 12 a.m Eastern Time
the hatches are configured to be open so
we are just standing by for that final
go call to the crew
will remain on air through their welcome
ceremony
where you get to hear some words from
the crew themselves on their flight as
well as what they plan for this time on
board
afterwards we will wrap our show as the
crew steps into their safety briefings
and eventually gets to work aboard the
space station
Dragon SpaceX on two for hatch open
hey Peggy so just big picture following
hatch open we'd like you to complete
part C of two decimal 102 prior to
station Ingress we're still ahead of the
timeline so we've got some time to
complete these tasks in the nominal
sequence
with that you are go for hatch opening
per decal followed by the remaining
actions and procedure 4 decimal 400
section 6.
detail and section c
[Applause]
that's affirmative pegging and uh
section six of four decimal 400 as well
decimal 400 as well thank you
and we've got a view here in Dragon
Freedom as Ali alcarni Works to open the
dragon side of the hatch
on the other side of the Dragon hatch is
NASA astronaut Woody hoberg waiting to
welcome the crew on board after having
completed all the preparations this
morning
in Houston in SpaceX Dragon hatch is
open
Houston copies
SpaceX copies
at 10 A.M
Central Time the dragon hatch is open
preparing to see our crew members float
through and join the International Space
Station
Houston the imv duct is installed and we
are ready for imv activation
Houston copies
again Dragon hatch open at 10 A.M
central time after docking at 8 12 a.m
Central Time following their
approximately 16-hour Journey from the
space coast of Florida to the
International Space Station
in Houston State uh station uh in the
dragon we're at six decimal three
um ready for the
procedures for the Lyle
copy that Peggy Houston is checking
Dragon Houston on the big loop you have
a go for step six decimal three and
procedure 2.102
go for six decimal
382.102 thanks
again we are preparing for
the ax2 crew to float through the dragon
hatch and join the space station crew on
the right hand side of your screen you
see NASA astronaut Woody hoberg who has
monitored their arrival this morning
first in the cupola and then worked to
prepare these Hatches pressurizing the
vestibule that space between both
hatches and eventually assisting in
opening the a-pass hatch as well as then
Ali al-karni just at 10 A.M Central Time
five minutes ago opening the dragon
hatch
again this is live coverage of the
arrival of the ax2 crew to the
International Space Station we are just
standing by for those crew members to
make their way out of dragon and into
the space station moments from
UAE astronaut Sultan al-nayadi just
floating out of screen on the uh right
hand side there he has been working
alongside Woody hoberry this morning to
prepare the hatches for the crew to
float through as well as monitoring
their arrival
both hoberg and olneyadi arrived as part
of the crew 6 crew
and are now both members of expedition
69 living and working aboard the
International Space Station
teams are also preparing the intermodule
ventilation that was the tube that we
saw earlier that Woody hoberg was
working with they will route that from
the station side into the dragon side to
help equalize the atmospheres between
both dragon and station
currently the International Space
Station is flying 264 statute miles
Southwest of Fiji
they are in an orbital night time and
here we have a great view of four of our
crew members on the International Space
Station
on the far left that's NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen down in the bottom left NASA
not Frank Rubio Houston on two lyocard
1308.
puppies
NASA's Woody hoberg was on the right of
your screen and in the center sultan
al-nayadi
again preparations to egress Dragon
continue and you can hear
Commander Peggy Whitson discussing with
teams on the ground that they are still
stepping through those final checks
for
um procedures you want us to continue on
step seven
yeah it's affirmative on Section step
seven
again hatches between both dragon and
the International Space Station are open
teams and dragon are the astronauts and
dragon just continuing their final
checkouts before moving into the space
station side where they will conduct
their welcome ceremony
all the valves are closed including the
ptrv isil
is Basics copies thanks
again this is a view from inside node 2
also known as Harmony the uh
ax2 crew today docked to the Zenith or
space facing Port there is another
Dragon spacecraft dock to the
forward-facing
portation is complete that's the eight
decimal nine of two one zero two
Houston copies
SpaceX copies
This Crew part of the seven that are on
the International Space Station
patiently waiting there are four new
crew members to arrive for the next
eight days
not pictured in this Frame there are
also three risk Cosmos cosmonauts on
board including Sergey prokopia of
Dimitri Palin and Andre fajaya so with
the addition of these four crew members
about to float on the space station we
will have an 11 total astronauts on
station
and we have our first views of the Axiom
crew members floating aboard first is
Commander Peggy Wilson
rejoining the International Space
Station
next up is pilot John schoffner making
his first visit
also on his first trip to space you can
see Ali al-karni representing the Saudi
space commission all smiles as he floats
through the dragon hatch
and rounding out the Axiom 2 Crew That's
Rihanna barnawi also of the Saudi space
Commission
the crew of the space station is now 11
crew members
big smiles from Rihanna barnawi she is
now the first female Saudi to go to
space
with Commander Peggy Whitson at the helm
these astronauts are in good hands Peggy
has 665 days already lived in space
she's just adding to that total on this
mission
John schoffner his first trip to space
getting some help out from Woody hoberg
NASA astronaut who is also on his first
trip to space he's been on the space
station now for 81 days
again the total number of astronauts and
cosmonauts on board the International
Space Station now at 11
three of the astronauts on the space
station represent NASA three represent
Russ Cosmos
to represent the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
one represents the United Arab Emirates
again we are standing by for the start
of the welcome ceremony the crew will
take some time to do some scene and
voice checks and make sure that their
microphones are set up properly as well
as that we have them all in frame before
going into their welcome remarks and of
course afterward we will wrap our
coverage before they step into their
work and life aboard the International
Space Station for the next eight days
station Houston on two for Frank and Pio
hello
hey Frank I just want to tag up with you
on the Pio event uh we're thinking about
doing a scene invoice in about seven
minutes from now uh will that work for
you
that'll be perfect uh we will call you
back in about uh and we can even do five
minutes if you guys all but we'll call
you back in seven minutes
that we prefer closer to seven minutes
as we have a Handover in about five
minutes from now
that's great
as you heard the Capcom relay to NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio we are expecting a
Handover
we're expecting that short Handover in
just a few minutes we want to make sure
that we have great audio and video from
our visiting astronauts so we are
holding for that short hand over and
then we will start the welcome ceremony
again you arrived this morning at 8 12
a.m Central Time the dragon hatch
opening at 10 A.M central time and then
crew members floating aboard just
moments ago
Ali alcarnia looks like he already has
the hang of things on his first flight
to space
the Axiom crew has trained for months in
preparation for this mission
the Axiom crew has been training for
months in preparation for this Mission
here at Johnson Space Center as well as
at SpaceX
working with teams on the research that
they will be conducting as well as
learning space station systems
three countries represented here we've
got uh tan alnayadi of UAE two risk
Cosmos cosmonauts as well as our two new
uh
astronauts representing the Saudi space
Commission on their eight-day stay on
the International Space Station
just above
barnawi and Al Carney's heads you can
see the two emu's extravacular Mobility
units used by Usos astronauts on
spacewalks
those have been moved from the airlock
to allow a little more space for the ash
the Axiom crew
during this flight of course we do have
11 crew members on board now so we have
to make some room for Sleep spaces
and again we are standing by
anticipating a satellite Handover here
momentarily
once we've regained Communications we'll
go through some voice checks with the
astronauts and there it is as expected
that Handover from our satellites we'll
do those scene in voice text when we
come back to make sure that we have a
picture perfect view of the crew members
before they give us some welcome remarks
this view from International Space
Station flight control room here in
Houston Texas teams continue to monitor
the arrival of our four new visitors as
well as all of the systems aboard the
International Space Station and the
astronauts and cosmonauts that live
there
just over two hours now since the ax2
crew arrived to the Zenith or
space-facing port on the harmony module
also known as node 2 that docking coming
at 8 12 a.m Central Time hatch opening
about 26 minutes ago 10 a.m Central Time
so we should regain that video and audio
communication with the space station
momentarily
on Houston Station on two for student
voice check
hey Frank we are ready for seeing a
voice whenever you guys are ready and as
a reminder you'll be on the handheld mic
for today's event
sounds good and uh let us know if that
scene works for you and then I can do
the countdown whenever you're ready
Frank if you wouldn't mind if you gather
everybody into their spots uh we'll
we'll take a look at the scene once
everyone's in place
crew members begin to move into their
locations for the welcome ceremony
obviously we have regain Communications
through the tracking data and relay
satellite systems
say again first team invoice
hey Woody we just want to get everyone
to everyone into position before we do
our scene check
all right we copy we'll group up
like I said earlier looking at a pretty
full house here aboard the International
Space Station
we have the crew that uh
will fly on
soyuz ms-23 to return home later this
year as well as the crew that arrived on
crew 6 and now the ax2 crew
Frank Houston on two good scene check we
didn't hear audio on the handheld Mike
can you check the switch position
Frank we're checking the config on the
ground standby
Frank if you wouldn't mind give us
another long count we needed to sync
things up
thanks Frank we're good on scene and
voice
station this is Houston are you ready
for the event
Houston this is station we are ready for
the event
please begin the welcome ceremony
Houston and SpaceX congratulations on a
beautiful launch and a beautiful dogging
it is great to have new friends up here
and so on behalf of expedition 69 it's
an honor to welcome our new crewmates
I'll pass it off to the ISS Commander
Sergey prokopiev
welcome on board dear friends this is a
very nice to see you here Expedition 69
uh so glad to hear uh have you here with
us on this station and
we looked forward you your arrival here
at least one month and I watched
yesterday your amazing launch and uh
this is a outstandable returning first
stage of Falcon 9 on the launch path
it's so grateful and congratulations
with a successful launch and your
docking and as for me this is very great
it's honor to work next with Peggy
Vision so the most experienced and
decorated astronauts in U.S astronaut
core and congratulations uh new
astronauts Ariana
Ali and
my congratulations to all of us
we have an hour 11 person on space
station and
my big congratulations of Saudi space
commission and I'm sure you will have a
great achievement in the future in your
space exploration uh thank you so much
and welcome Albert
thank you so much Sarah
thank you so much we really are excited
to
uh it was a great launch a great ride we
had a lot of fun on the way up and we're
really excited to get a lot of work done
up here but it's it's uh it's great for
me to come back personally it does feel
like home
you might need some help though for a
while I could help you with some of
these things but
it's uh it's a lot of fun to be here and
to see this place again it means so much
to me and I think it's it it actually
brings people together just by being
here so I wanted you to meet my crew so
I want each of them to talk a little bit
about their objectives and why they're
here and maybe a little bit about the
ride
part of the ax2 crew uh it's it's an
honor to be here and make new friends in
Space the first time I've done that for
sure so
you I've been dreaming or working toward
this since I was eight in a young
astronauts Club you know watching Gemini
Pilots do their thing so we had
cardboard boxes pretending to be General
Pilots so you think be having that much
time to prepare I'd have some better
words than this but uh you know it's uh
having a chance to be here and uh fly
with this amazing uh new crew uh Ollie
and Ray and of course with Peggy Whitson
the awesome Peggy Whitson
and to join Expedition 69 is a fabulous
thing for me for anyone to be able to do
I'm honored I'd like to thank NASA for
creating the opportunity and opening the
doors for private and commercial space
exploration uh and also the Ingenuity of
SpaceX and Axiom and to develop the next
level of space platforms and space
access for everyone I want to say thanks
to my lovely wife for those magic words
one day she looked on the news and said
look you can you can finally go to space
she was right thank you for that Janine
uh otherwise we look forward to some
great work for stem education Outreach
and some amazing science that we have
going on up here and I hope you guys
will follow us thank you very much
thank you John this is uh audio Carney
uh if you just allow me to start
speaking in Arabic first uh Bismillah
alhamdulillah
um
[Music]
thank you everybody for the uh great uh
World committee such an honor and a
privilege to be here and meet all of you
as John said making space friends so uh
I would I'm I'm really excited to work
alongside uh with you all of you and
eager to uh
to just share uh the ex your expertise
with me I learned from you uh thank you
thank you to our King and his Crown
Prince for their support and Trust in us
thank you to the Saudi people because
this mission is not just for me Ariana
this mission is also the people with
ambition and dreams and and also you can
dream big because uh in in our country
with the support we have we will be able
to reach it thank you everybody
hello everyone so this is Jana barnawi
um so if you allow me I'll start in
Arabic first
um
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
so Greetings From Outer Space
um I'm here not only representing myself
but representing the hopes and dreams of
everyone back home everyone in the
region we are here Gathering
um with different uh cultures and and
and this International collaboration
this shows how space brings everyone
together it brings even different
backgrounds where some of us are doctors
some of us are researchers engineers and
so on I'm very happy to be here
representing uh the dreams and hopes of
everyone back home and at the same time
I'm very glad that I've received
extensive training from trainers who
have trained previous astronauts and
like NASA Jackson Issa and SpaceX and
Axiom I'm very happy to be here and
thank you all for listening thank you
for letting me share my feelings things
and I'm gonna live this experience to
the max
great well we all are excited for all of
the new astronauts here and we have
something special Ray would you hold
this while I pin John oh wow
give him his official astronaut pin
John is the
598 astronauts
[Applause]
I think I'm ready for slapping yet
Mike is off
so Ollie is the
599th astronaut
and our little Ray is 600. laughs
I'm gonna stick myself more than
anything okay here we go all right
so thanks to inviting all of us up here
and welcoming three new astronauts
[Applause]
okay and that concludes the uh ceremony
thank you guys so much again it really
feels like the International Space
Station up here uh this is going to be
an awesome week we're all excited and uh
super happy to have you guys up here
station this is Houston ACR thank you
that concludes our event
thank you to all participants station we
are now resuming operational Auto
Communications
and with completion of the welcome
ceremony another big welcome to the
Axiom 2 crew our second private
astronaut Mission crew to arrive at the
International Space Station we now have
11 people living and working on the
International Space Station again we're
looking for those ax2 crew members to
live and work on the orbiting lab for
the next eight days
we saw docking this morning at 8 12 a.m
Central Time 9 12 a.m Eastern and hatch
opening from dragon to the International
Space Station at 10 Central 11 Eastern
all of this following launch yesterday
at 5 37 PM Eastern from Florida it was a
smooth ride uphill approximately 16
hours ahead of that docking today and
again now we are expecting these crew
members to live and work on the space
station for about eight days before
beginning their journey home to Earth so
for future updates on NASA missions as
well as what you can expect from the ax2
crew on their return coverage you can
keep an eye on nasa.gov but with that
that'll wrap us up here in Mission
Control Houston and I'm going to send it
back to my friends at SpaceX
thank you so much Leah excellent
coverage from Johnson Space Center
really following along with all the
integrated operations that ultimately
led us to what a touching welcoming
ceremony now with that we are going to
wrap up our live joint coverage of Peggy
John Ali and Rihanna's arrival to the
International Space Station it's been an
honor to support the ax2 mission thus
far we wish the Axiom crew a successful
time on station and we look forward to
joining you when it's time to bring them
back home absolutely and Kate I just
want to say from launch to docking it
has been an absolute pleasure sharing
this desk with you so thank you spasiba
and shukran
over the course of our cruise time on
station we will be providing daily
mission updates from Axiom Mission
Control to highlight the range of
science research and steam education
events the crew will be conducting over
the course of their eight days on
station be sure to visit axiomspace.com
and follow the Axiom social media
channels for real-time updates and with
that on behalf of SpaceX Axiom space and
NASA thank you all for tuning in to
watch see you soon
[Music]
thank you